good morning my name is Ben Busby and I
am the genomics outreach coordinator for
NCBI thank you for coming to our short
informal webinar series the NCBI minute
our NCBI minute installment this week is
going to be on bio project a fast way to
get genomic data from NCBI a video
recording of this webinar will be
available on our YouTube channel very
soon and please remember to subscribe to
our YouTube channel also all of the
questions that you guys ask will be
available in this document after the
webinar so I'd like to tell you in 3
minutes or less how to get the genomic
data you want from NCBI if you were to
search for a term like Mouse or
tuberculosis in the traditional entre
search you would get somewhere on the
order of 8 million hits per mouse anyway
the advantage of using the bio project
database is that there is a faceted
search bar on the left for example if I
wanted RNA seek data I could facet by
transcriptome and SRA SRA is the
sequence read archive where we keep our
next-generation sequencing data and then
that would specifically give me RNA seek
data sets for mouse similarly if I want
an epigenetic data
I confess it by epigenomics if I click
on one example of this I believe it's
the fourth or fifth link down I get one
particular project so here I get an
umbrella project of 224 SRA experiments
like - a PubMed abstract and also geo
data sets which are pre analyzed data
analyzed by the investigators that
submitted this data some of the features
of this are being able to look at the
abstract that they've submitted to
bioproject
now what you'll notice is this is a much
more data centered abstract than the
corresponding PubMed apps
which really talks about the entire
study and the paper that they have
published if we go back to bioproject we
can also click on the link for SRA
experiments note that this is an active
link we can go there and then once we
get to SRA we can send those to
something called the run selector from
the send to button and then we're able
to filter farther via this solar-based
filtering here on the left for example
if I wanted to filter by assembly name I
can select assembly name here and select
grch37 also if I go to the SRA data and
go to the send to button I can select
some of these studies and send them to
my standard blast interface in that way
I can blast any particular gene or
nucleotide sequence that I'm interested
in in to these SRA runs and as we can
see here I get a standard blast output
soon we will also have this output
available in Sam format finally I'd like
to talk about reporting so as many of
you know the NIH genomic data sharing
standards will be in effect as September
2015
P eyes will have to document sharing of
data with public repositories such as
NCBI bioproject accession numbers make
it very easy for PI's to document their
genomic data sharing projects in the NIH
grant project review system so once
again thank you very much for attending
art in CBI minute my name is Ben Busby
please subscribe to our YouTube channel
and have a great day